[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play flat bow now
some of you may know that I actually do
not like the idea of flappy bird
I don't mind it as a game because it has
all the features that make it game but
flappy bird as a phenomenon I do not
enjoy and when it was meeting its end by
the hands of its creator I couldn't have
been happier but game's old had this
thing called flappy bird game jam flap
jam or whatever it was called and in
this game jam came out this game called
flat bound based loosely based loosely
on earthbound which is one of my
favorite games of all time that came out
for the Super Nintendo Entertainment
System way back in like 93 or something
like that and it controls as much as you
would expect with a few with a few
interesting things thrown in its fins
whenever when flappy bird first came out
um and it started to get popular I of
course installed it on my phone to give
it a try
I played two rounds and promptly
uninstalled it because good god this
whole idea
i I didn't even want to get involved in
but everyone I mean everyone has been
demanding that I play flappy bird and
I'm like no I will not I refuse to do
this but you know I saw an opportunity
here with this particular game and now
the whole world gets to see how bad I am
at got gigabit I don't hate it because
I'm bad it and I hate it because it's
not the type of game that I would enjoy
actually I don't want to play it because
it's the game that I would easily get
addicted to that's the problem with
flappy bird is it's something that god
damn it it's something that you could
easily get addicted to in this
particular version of it is just
charming enough and I
want to play it I love the music of
earthbound and I love the feel of
earthbound a tie it's one of my closest
childhood memories because I remember
playing through it and my brother who
can probably hear me right now would
agree earthbound is a great game this is
an abomination good but I'm still
playing it because you bastards wanted
me to ah let's see if I can get to ten
ten would be delightful wouldn't it and
if you know anything about earthbound
these erasers and pencils actually make
a bit of sense it has been a while since
I played the game but God seven-day new
record I'm just so happy for myself what
did I do
I didn't do anything it said I lost all
motivation but I press the button you
son of a [ __ ] did I take too long to
get started you a-hole huh
alright one two buckle my shoe three
four four this game out the door five
six I'd rather pick up sticks don't know
seven eight yeah new record what is that
floating balloon there's like this
present meter with ten on it and I don't
know what that means one we're gonna be
here a while it's been a bit of a long
morning for me as well trying to get
this thing in or trying to get the
motivation to record today you know uh
let me just tell you how good my morning
started out come I'm over at my old room
and I don't have a lot of things that
were in my apartment such as the stuff
that I use to keep my hair up so in a
fit of brilliant system yeah I don't
know what that
god damn it so in a fit of brilliance
this Oh got something Oh God Oh what is
this baloney ah okay
let's concentrate a bit here as I tell
my story in a fit of brilliance this
morning I didn't have any of the stuff
that to keep my hair in such a gun and
such a beautiful and delightful know
what did I do
oh come on so naive gonna make the
excuse said I was like tired or
something I decided that since I didn't
have anything I use I would put butter
in my hair and why am I here now I
decided that it would that of all the
things that I could have used in my
house to keep my hair up butter would
have been the best substitute and it
wasn't even the situation where I was
like yeah I don't have any other options
it was the first idea that I had and
then I went with it because I'm
brilliant in that and it kind of works
that doesn't make it seem like it was
that much of a bad idea until I realized
that now everything stinks of butter and
my hair is disgusting
in every way and if you're all like no
no no one could be that stupid no one
could possibly think that was a good
idea well I have the butter to prove it
and right here this stick of butter that
I put in my hair to try to make it stand
up this is the culmination of my
intelligence my brilliance in the four
years I took engineering biomedical
engineering by the way
this is the this is this is my
intelligence this is the level and
understanding of what I can do in and as
I'm trying to talk and beat this stupid
game called flat bound based goddamn
fudgesicles I'm trying to beat this I'm
guessing the boxes or checkpoints to
unlock new levels but I'm never ever
ever ever ever ever ever gonna be able
to get passes I press the space button
it's all about hitting the flap at the
right moment so that you don't get
caught as a douchenozzle
oh because it can't possibly get it damn
it
it can't possibly get any worse I
shouldn't say that because it's a it's a
different mechanic in here because that
they come two points and the points are
I don't know you know what maybe it's
actually easier and I'm just and I'm
just I'm just the [ __ ] you know that
could be it maybe I'm just wrong
I've always how long have I been playing
this game when can I stop have no idea
I'm I don't want to do bad but I'm like
it's weird with flabby bird because
you're like challenged to go farther and
I know maybe if I go over it it'd be
easier maybe I could find a bug to break
this game maybe I can't break it because
it's already so damn broken but no I
double tap I'm gonna twitchy and nervous
god damn it and I keep going into this
weird
I filmed wanna do this I'm actually
gonna try okay though maybe I'm not
everything stinks of butter in my room
it's why am i doing this to myself why
why am I doing this I I'm all twitchy
I'm all twitchy but oh I'm calm I'm
collected buzzer nutters piece of ass
two three I don't I wish this shadow
world is trippy as balls which is like
this game is solely terming and that yes
it is exactly like Earth bounded and
oddly it fits the theme oddly it fits it
so well that ah I want this game to be
the successor the main successor double
abbey bird but one last ride god this is
why this is why the game was so
successful because I can't do it I can't
do it I go how did I even get through
one how did I ever get to twelve I don't
know
oh yeah nope I'm done okay so I've been
progressively getting worse this game is
the devil itself I can't do it I'm just
gonna let myself fly and die that's all
I care about
oh so that was flap bound if you're
looking for a charming spin on flappy
bird then here you go
links in the description I hate it with
a burning passion but then again I'm an
idiot so don't take my opinion I put
butter in my hair today hope you have a
better day than I am so thank you all so
much for watching and as always I'll see
you in the next video
[Music]